>> So it can be a little bit weird to talk about the truth value of
an implication sentence. What we're really saying here is, whether or
not this implication actually holds true. So let's take
three different implications to see this. First let's think of the implication,
feathers implies bird. All birds have feathers and only birds have feathers. So,
we know that if an animal has feathers, then it is a bird. That's true.
On the other hand, let's take the implication, if scales then bird. Lots of
animals with scales aren't birds and in fact no animals with scales are birds.
So the implication, scales implies birds. Would be False. For our third example,
let's take the implication, flight implies bird. If we have a penguin,
flight is False. But the penguin is still a bird. So, flight can be false and
bird can still be true, meaning the implication can still be true here.
On the other hand, if we have a cat, flight if False. And bird is False.
So, the implication can still be true. So in this case, if flight was false,
we can't actually make a determination on whether or not the animal is a bird.